hey youtubers is Charlie this is going
to be my Game of Thrones time-travel
video there's a big theory about bran
stark the three-eyed Raven so just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened so far we've seen a lot
of flashbacks with the three-eyed Raven
and bran looking at different pieces of
Robert's rebellion things leading up to
the origin of certain characters certain
big events that we read about in the
books and a lot of people have wondered
whether or not brain has the ability to
influence the past the three-eyed Raven
has said the past has already been
written the ink is already dry so he's
implying the bran can't do anything to
change the past to alter the timeline
but what I think is happening here is he
wants Brandt's learn about the past so
that he can affect his own future you
can't change what already happened but
you can change what might end up
happening most of his storyline has been
consumed with learning about the war for
the dawn learning who the most important
players are how they figure into the
grand scheme of things and how he can
use them to defeat the white walkers so
you learn about Jon Snow Daenerys any of
the other characters that you feel like
might make it to the end
we'll probably be tied to brands
flashbacks and even though the
three-eyed Raven is dead now that
doesn't mean the brand can't still go
back he has all the powers of the
three-eyed Raven so taking a bigger step
up on the tinfoil ladder the latest
theory that I've seen is what if brand
really is the three-eyed Raven
the three-eyed Raven is an older version
of brand who travelled to the past to
teach himself about the war for the dawn
the problem with that is that it flies
in the face of a lot of book canon it's
an interesting 12 monkeys spin on the
idea that bran really can affect the
past because it seems like Ned Stark
young Ned Stark here can hear him when
he whispers but when you read the books
and you read about these flashbacks it's
described as much more like what you
would think a tree would sound like if
it were talking to you like the rustling
of wind and leaves like you feel like
you might hear something but you can't
quite make out the words so that's what
I think is happening on the show it's
just that they're being very opaque
about it
I think there'd be more merit to the
idea of him changing the past had the
three-eyed raven not had that line of
dialogue where he said the ink is
already dry so even if brands able to
have a low level of communication with
people in the past like Ned Stark could
kind of hear him nothing he could do
would change events in a meaningful way
feel like the episode 5 Hodor twist is
really what threw people for a loop
because bran is warden to Hodor while
he's also in the past so there's kind of
this continuous link from the future to
the past so young Willis here is able to
hear Meera shouting hold the door and
it's such a psychically traumatic event
it is brain just gets stuck on the idea
of hold the door and his speech that
like the speech centers of his brain are
affected so that's all he can say is
just him having a slight effect on an
event that was going to play out that
way no matter what so really the
takeaway is is that you could believe
that brand can affect the past but he
can't change what's going to happen so I
know a lot of people are like what if he
whispered to the Mad King and tried to
change the past what if the three-eyed
Raven tried to change the past and he's
the one that led to the Mad King
becoming mad when you think about it
really what's happening is as the Mad
King was always going to be mad so no
matter what the three-eyed Raven might
have tried to whisper to him it didn't
fundamentally alter anything that he
ended up doing but here's the really
interesting idea that we haven't talked
too much about I definitely do think the
three-eyed Raven has gone back and
looked at the long night he's seen all
of history and that's what he's trying
to show bran
we're seeing the first night's king
presumably the show has changed the
timeline a little it's compressed things
so the long night of the TV show sounds
like it's a thousand years ago instead
of the eight thousand years ago that it
is in the books so he's taking brand a
thousand years into the past to witness
the birth of the first night's king so
if he's gone back that far then the
three-eyed Raven has probably jumped all
over the timeline just to get more
information on things and bran will
probably continue to do that but he
doesn't have full command over his
powers it really took Dan and Dave
clarifying things after the episode last
week where they said the three-eyed
Raven once he realizes the night's king
is coming to kill them he tries to
upload all of his information to brand
but in that moment he tells brand that
it's time for you to become me really
what he's saying is it's time for you to
be the last greenseer to take up my
cause but I think the source of that
brand as three-eyed Raven theory just
comes from that line where they're like
maybe the three-eyed Raven is literally
bran
but when you look at the books the the
reason it flies in the face of book
canon is that the three-eyed Raven is
named Brendan rivers that was his
original name he was one of the bastards
of the Targaryen King that set off the
first Blackfyre
in it was his big period in Westerosi
history it's really interesting if you
guys haven't read it yet but he got a
bunch of different names he had this
long history he's about 200 years old in
the books they called him Lord
Bloodraven as a green seer he had very
powerful magic eventually he took the
black became Lord Commander and then one
day just kind of wandered north of the
wall never to be seen again but
presumably that's when he came to this
weirwood to start focusing more on the
war for the dawn but the TV show has
really like skipped over all that so
that's why a lot of people are like
maybe he's future brand so we can
definitely pour water on that the
three-eyed Raven is a totally different
person from bran just a person like
brand who was a green seer that learned
about the war for the dawn that he had
an important role to play but sometimes
the show can be a little confusing with
the way it explains things there was a
line of dialogue that he had earlier
where he talked about a thousand years
of history making it sound like he was
implying he was a thousand years old
really he's closer to 200 years old
the other big example of this is the
night's king this is I think where we're
talking about the TV show diverging from
the books dan and Dave have said that
but they've been really opaque about
which parts are vastly diverged because
they said the george RR martin told them
about this big twist with the White
Walkers being created by the children of
the forest they told them about the
Hodor reveal so you have to think of the
TV show as CliffsNotes for the books so
while it seems like there's only one
night's King on the TV show they've
actually been many like when people talk
about the historical night's king of the
books the thirteenth Lord Commander that
may or may not have been a stark george
RR martin clarified after season four
that the mythical night's king probably
lived and died during the Age of Heroes
like land the clever or bran the Builder
back to the time-travel theory here's
another interesting idea about bran
what if brand is all of the brands like
what if he's bran the Builder a lot of
people are just wondering if he's able
to influence the past in that way and
based on what George R Martin has said
and based on what the books have said I
think that's not true but let me know in
the comments even if you haven't read
any of the stuff that George our Martin
is answer sometimes he'll answer
questions about the books like that do
you think the brand can literally affect
the past as they go back and prevent
someone from dying like do you think if
he really wanted to he could try to find
a way to prevent Ned Stark from being
beheaded I just I feel
like all that is set in stone so even if
he could speak to his father he wouldn't
be able to change the fact that he got
beheaded but new episode of Game of
Thrones tonight there is a new round of
the giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video it's just a $20 Amazon
gift card so I'll post my episode 6
video after it airs I'm hoping we get
some more brand flashbacks but I think
they're more worried about escaping that
army of whites right now but we've
actually gotten a couple big twists in
almost every single episode so I am
expecting something really awesome
while you guys wait for that video to
post you can click here to learn about
how the actor who plays Ramsay Bolton
wants Ramsay to die on the show and you
can click here for my hold the door
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you